there are places out there you can't
find on any map
they're not gone
they're just lost
congratulations on uncharted you brought
nathan drake to the big screen i saw
that the game director also loved your
casting which is like the
greatest thing to read right
was there a scene or level from the
uncharted games that impressed or
inspired you well i mean there's so many
throughout all four games uh you know
obviously in the film we have a sequence
where nathan is sort of thrown out the
back of an airplane and he is trying to
clamber his way up back we call it the
daisy chain when we were shooting it
he's trying to climb his way back
through these boxes to obviously get
back into the plane to safety that is a
a sequence that's heavily influenced
from the games um you know something
that we you know we went through all the
games and picked different things that
we thought were achievable there are
sequences in the games that i just don't
think we could pull off they're that
impressive uh but you know we definitely
did take influence from from the games i
mean but you pulled that one off which
is just like
mind blown was that the hardest thing
you've ever done like how did you train
and how did you shoot that scene of you
jumping over crates above the cargo
plane i mean it was it was incredibly
tough incredibly tough and you know i
had to train a lot and i got as strong
as i've ever been but the interesting
thing is uh
i basically wanted to put on as much
size as possible you know because next
to mark wahlberg i look like a rake so i
wanted to just get into shape and put on
as much weight as possible but in doing
that you know i didn't do any
cardiovascular
work because i didn't want to burn any
unnecessary calories in the gym
meaning that when we were shooting these
long sequences i was so unfit
like you'd ask me to run a mile and i
would have collapsed
so it was tough it was a sort of
double-edged sword of like i could do
pull-ups for days but if you ask me to
run a mile i'd fall apart oh my god and
what was it like shooting it like did
you come out unscathed because it just
looks so
physically intense
i mean there were there were times where
you know we ripped our hands to
smithereens you know like hanging onto
those boxes and eventually your grip
strength would give out and you would
just let go and upon letting go you'd
have rope burn and blisters and bangs
and bruises you know i unfortunately i
kicked a poor stunt man in the face in
that sequence he was okay he is an
ex-ufc fighter so he's tough as nails
that doesn't excuse
my
lack of judgment uh but just the way the
wire work had worked out i was closer to
him than usual and i booted him in the
face but he was okay which was good to
know uh so there's a lot of blood sweat
and tears that went into that sequence
one stunt man was harmed in the making
no i'm sitting here he was bless him
greg had a really nasty one actually
greg at one point had to go through a
wall and they call it scoring the wall
and what that actually means is they cut
it into many pieces and then they put it
back together so when the stunt men go
through it it kind of shatters but they
forgot to score one piece and it went
into greg's leg and he had the fattest
bruise on his on the back of his leg but
he loves it he was pulling his trousers
down showing everyone he he's he loves
that sort of stuff
he's got a battle wound now uncharted
battle and that's so cool thanks for
telling me about scoring i didn't know
that um i laughed so hard when you said
you were like a rake next to mark
wahlberg yeah fun seeing you guys share
the screen together and i was thinking
tom like you've had some pretty cool
mentors on screen
uh let's talk about the pros and cons of
having tony stark and sully as a mentor
i mean there are interesting people
uh to say the least um you know there
are
parts of both of those characters that
are incredibly admirable
and people that are easy to look up to
but that doesn't mean that they're not
incredibly flawed the whole crux of
spider-man far from home is that he gave
a sort of multi-billion pound weaponized
pair of sunglasses to a 17 year old i
don't think that was the best idea but
it did make for a pretty great film and
then sully obviously is the most
distrusting person an untrustworthy
person in the world obviously as the
film progresses there is an arc to his
character but you know there are pros
and cons to both of them what are some
pros to having them as your mentors i
mean they're both very kind they're
adventurous um you know they are very
handy in a fight you know i would always
feel safe having mark wahlberg around
and especially having downey around i
mean he's like a master in wing chun
so there's that and they're also just
lovely people they're nice to be around
you're nice to be around too though and
it was so cool to see you bring nathan
drake to life i hope there's a lot more
to come from that but now that you've
brought nathan to life is there any
other video game character that you
would want to team up with
i mean the natural one to say would be
lara croft uh you know there is a
synergy between the two characters and
in the sort of adventure adventures that
they um go on
i don't know who owns lara croft i don't
know what studio who makes that film so
i'm not sure how that will work but sony
and tom rossman being you know the
incredible studio head that he is he has
made a deal with disney with spider-man
that has never been done before so i'm
sure he has all of the skills in his
back pocket to make a deal if they
wanted to do an uncharted lara croft
team up uh which actually could be
really fun that would be a really cool
idea for a film but whether or not that
is what it is who knows that would be
sick and if it happens you said it here
first i thought you were gonna say maybe
chris pratt because he's gonna be
voicing mario really
chris pratt is gonna voice mario yeah
you didn't know that i didn't know that
that's awesome i've been trying to keep
off of social media for the last few
months so i've been a little bit un
living under a rock so that's amazing
that's a cool little piece of casting
both you turn your keys clockwise at the
same time
thanks a lot he almost got me killed
clockwise sully well it was 50 50 so i
made a guess clearly congratulations on
uncharted it was so cute you and tom
share the screen together and it made me
want to ask you have you seen spiderman
no way home yet and what'd you think of
the movie and tom as spider-man i
haven't seen it yet but i am now
learning about the multiverse
yes um i was wondering and i started
asking these questions we were just on
an interview together and i'm like how
can you have
the first spider-man the second
spider-man and now the third one all in
the same movie uh but they explained it
to me
uh i'm not completely convinced that
it's okay but i'm going to go and see it
my kids have seen it in the theater but
tom is it's fantastic i really enjoyed
working with him he's super talented and
you know he's really finding a way to
balance these kind of big huge
successful tent poles with doing really
small interesting challenging dramatic
work so uh he's doing it right
did you guys get a chance to talk about
spider-man at all and like have you like
would you want to be in a sequel or
would you want to play a character in
that spider-man yeah not necessarily i
think it would depend i think um
you know i'm kind of getting older and
trying to do different things and
embracing that so if i could play uncle
ben or one of those parts then maybe but
you know i i'm uh no i'm kind of i i
certainly couldn't walk out of my
trailer in one of those outfits i don't
have the confidence
listen i would love to see mark wahlberg
as uncle ben but let's talk about
uncharted now you have this insane fight
scene with tati gabrielle's braddocks i
wanted to know what was it like shooting
that scene it was tough tati's really
she's she's badass i mean sure her
martial arts skills all that stuff are
amazing but her and i became fast
friends before we even started making
the film
so anytime we got to just play off of
each other
and just working together was always a
big treat she's uh she was probably and
i loved everybody else in the movie but
obviously i was closest to tati uh she's
amazing
nice you come out unscathed because that
fight scene was insane
i did pretty much i mean she like she
was choking me
she was choking me out she wrapped that
thing around my neck a little too tight
but i didn't want to complain i didn't
want to know that i was bothered by it
and uh
you know she's you talk about a
formidable opponent both not just
physically but mentally and emotionally
she's she's wonderful yeah it was cool
to see that i mean this film is just so
action-packed aside from that fight
scene and i remember watching an
interview you did mark two weeks before
you started filming uncharted where you
were telling the interviewer when you
read the script you were just like this
feels like a real movie so i was
wondering did you get to do anything in
uncharted that you hadn't done before in
a movie um yeah i mean i probably i've
cause i've done so much i've probably
done it all but it was the first time
that i just felt like i was in a big
movie like this felt like indiana jones
where you're transported into a world
and you're seeing something that you're
just normally not privy to seeing that's
why it always just felt like that you
know i've done these little intimate
movies i've done many different kinds of
films but this is the first big like
action adventure blockbuster that takes
you on this magical mystical ride that
uh is full of adventure and joy it
really is like you're literally on your
like at the edge of your seat until the
very end right after i right after i
read i literally watched every one of
the indiana joneses and then i watched
you know romancing the stone and other
movies that i felt like had some sort of
similarities i was i i also thought of
indiana jones but i thought it was
interesting that this movie started out
as a concept of wanting to make a movie
about a younger james bond and i wanted
to who would you cast as double 07. uh
idris alba
why just
because he's he's just the smoothest
coolest uh a guy there is out there
obviously he's tall good looking all
that stuff but he's got the edge and
everything else and you know um daniel
craig has been fantastic but that would
that would be my first choice yeah
that's my first choice too i'm just like
waiting for them to announce it i'd be
so excited um
do you see this uncharted film series as
a trilogy and like have you guys talked
about this being a sequel or they're
being we haven't i'm not usually in the
world of sequels i've made a couple um
but you know i mean i always think if
the audience really wants it that's the
first thing and then if we can make it
better than the first
um then that then then it's worth
exploring
yeah well i'm secretly hoping for that
too as well wow um love that you're
rocking the stash i'm sure a lot of
people been asking you about that today
we see the mustache in the trailer is
this something that you'd also want to
keep like for sully and like for sully
yeah but this is also a tribute to my
dad my dad always rocked a mustache
remember when i had the mustache for the
movie my siblings like oh my god you
look so much like dad so kind of rocking
it for that and then maybe for another
part coming up but i if not i'll i'll i
might shave it soon after the movie
comes out
who the hell is this i'm a friend of
sully's sally doesn't have any friends i
should know him one of them
congratulations on uncharted i love
chloe frazier in this film i first
wanted to ask you
about that insane
cargo plane crate stunt scene
what was it like shooting
oh it was awesome it was so cool i felt
so badass and empowered and
yeah it was cool what was like can you
tell me how long it took to sort of
train for that stunt and what was it
like playing off tom too i'm curious and
what are your thoughts on his take on
nathan drake it's different than i
imagined it he's layered and nuanced
differently than his other characters
you know the rehearsal process was like
it was so much and and everything sort
of blends together because when we got
there on the day we would rehearse so
much and then everything would be so
different you know and that was sort of
the plane it was a lot of like fly by
the edge of your seat kind of stuff and
you know i was doing things i didn't
know i could do and just hoping that i
could do it wow what's something you did
that you didn't know you could do well
like any anything any action thing that
i did yeah like i slid across the car i
like jumped into the car through the
window i fought someone and uh i shot
guns i love it well you you executed it
flawlessly what i love about chloe
frazier too is that she has her own
she has her own video game so have you
thought of what you would like to see
in a chloe spin-off if that were to
happen yeah i want to see like her roots
you know i want to see her in india i
want to see her immersed in the culture
and she's very interesting character
right she's not like how you would
imagine
obviously i i doubt she really
identifies culturally with that at all
you know so to see her in that how she
adapts and changes and stuff that'd be
cool what do you love about chloe as a
character
i mean that's one thing i feel like
she's really adaptable
she's just smart she knows herself and
she knows most situations and
she's very very sure of herself
congratulations on uncharted the first
thing i wanted to ask you about was this
the insane fight scene that you have
with sully mark wahlberg i was talking
to him earlier today and he was like i
was closest with tati on set and there
was a moment like choking me too hard so
tell me all the ins and outs forgot
about that
wait tell me about that
so yeah like it was i mean yeah like i
feel like both of us like yeah mark was
like became like my uncle on set like he
really like mentored me through the
whole um shoot of this of this project
and that scene in particular like i feel
like neither of us are cutting either
any slack well like he told me to go for
it you know and then so i remember like
in between things and he
after one of the things he was like
jesus kid can you like well i was like
i'm so sorry i didn't
i was they told me to get into it to
look vicious and it's hard to like look
vicious and not like also have that
tension in your body so yeah it was it
was a lot of fun um and like he gave me
a hard time too like
that spin around
god i feel like the man dead weighted me
and like i had to strong-arm him all the
way around oh man
um but
definitely good memories from that scene
i love you're just bringing it to life
even more because i remember watching it
i was like omg this is intense what was
it like training for that and
and how was training for a knife fight i
i guess different than training for you
know other types of fights on screen
i yeah well training i mean the training
board in general is was pretty extensive
just as far as like the prep more so of
like getting like working with a trainer
to like get beefed up and everything and
like with
knife fighting is
only difficult in the way of learning
distance especially with the karambit
and it being this very particular sort
of thing of knowing how close or far you
need to be
to
i guess one in real life be able to hit
someone but two on screen be able to
make it look real um
and that like my work with the karambit
i did a lot of self-taught um things
like i just watched videos did research
the the fighting though in general came
a lot easier to me um because i have a
background in martial arts um and so um
that was pretty smooth yeah you were so
good as this character how fun is it
playing a villain and did you use any
other villains as inspiration
um it's awesome playing a villain i mean
like
it's just like when do you like get to
just
not care about anybody or anything
um
yeah it was also just like a fun
challenge like um i'm so different than
braddock like i'm actually quite
sensitive and very like optimistic and
bubbly and so like i had to really strip
away all of myself in order to truly be
this villainous unempathetic
psychopathic chick is it weird to say
that i you well i guess a combination of
like rafe and nadine from the video
games themselves
um was a big inspiration for me for
braddock and then i actually took from
prudence from my character from sabrina
and sort of i feel like infused a little
bit of that into braddock as well
that's so sick i love you and sabrina i
love you and you too
how do you how do you think braddock
would handle joe goldberg oh there would
be like it would not have gone on so
long like joe would be gone by now if he
came up against braddock oh my god have
you seen her she's psycho like no like
he wouldn't he would have lasted this
long
you